It's important not to forget to report on
proven lies from this administration even
when the story has left the headlines. And
case in point. We now have a declassified
internal white house memo about that assassination
of the Uranian crudes leader Kaseem Solemani,
which uh, but the, the memo now confirms that
the imminent threat posed by Solemani was
not actually part of the, uh, justification
that the white house internally was discussing
for his assassination. Something we suspected
at the time he was not a threat imminently
to the United States or U S interests.
And initially they changed the justification's.
But initially that was the primary justification
that the white house gave. Now remember that
the explanations shifted. First it was Sola
Moni was an imminent threat. He was planning
to do all sorts of violence, attack us embassies,
all sorts of stuff. When it started to become
very clear that that wasn't true, they shifted
to, well, this is because of the things that
Soleimani did in the past. And hilariously,
at one point, Trump and his secretary of state,
Mike Pompeo, who were not even on the same
page, Trump was repeating that it was because
of the imminent threat. While Palm PEO had
already shifted to saying it's because of
what he did in the past, then Trump ended
up tweeting, well, it doesn't even really
matter why I did it. Same quote, the fake
news media and their Democrat partners are
working hard to determine whether or not the
future attack by terrorists Soleimani was
imminent or not.
And was my team in agreement? The answer to
both is a strong yes, but it doesn't really
matter because of his horrible past. Well,
we now have the memo from the white house
just to kind of close this story out. And
imminent threat is nowhere in there. It's
another bogus, dishonest talking point debunked
ultimately by their own documents. The only
thing the memo says is that this was a response
to escalating attacks in prior months by Iran
and Iran backed militias. The attack was meant
to serve as a sort of scare off deterrent
to future attacks and it simply then goes
into the legal justification for why Donald
Trump was legally, uh, enabled and able to
do this attack. There was nothing there about
imminent threat. There's nothing there about
the imminence claim that they claim existed.
Now I know it's been weeks, people have already
forgotten about this, but it's important to
document the lies and we now have another
one confirmed. And in a sense we already had
it confirmed. Mike Palm PEO very quickly shifted
from imminent threat to repercussions for
past actions. Reminder of one of Palm payos
being slippery on this at the time
we needed to strike to make sure that this
imminent attack that he was working actively,
uh, was disrupted
a specific target overseas.
I'm not gonna say anything more about the
nature of the tech, but know that this was
not just in Iraq, was throughout the region.
I was using these proxy forces that he has
manipulated for so long to bring so much destruction,
uh, to the Shias and Sunni's the Muslims throughout
the region. This a man who inflicted enormous
harm, not only on American lives, but created
a terribly destructive activities. Sporting
Lebanese, Hezbollah, Hamas, the Palestinian
economic jihad. Uh, all of the bad actors
in the middle East, custom Sulaymani was that
the center of all of it?
Was there any imminent threat to the U S Homeland?
These were threats that were located in the
region,
right? I mean, I guess maybe some threat in
that region, not to the U S and anyway, it
was punishment for bad things he previously
did as they later went on to say and Trump
insisting he can do it either way, no matter
what. Then Palm PEO went on Fox news and said,
well, probably there was some threat. We just
didn't know when or where it would ultimately
manifest. And then it went back to, well,
no, no, it was actually punishment for Kaseem
Solomanis past bad deeds. It was a completely
incoherent shifting rationale from the start.
We knew they were lying and now the declassified
white house memo confirms this. Not that anybody
on Trump's side is going to care, but important
to do the work and to keep up with debunking
these lies and there are many of them and
they come fast
and furious.